this article tacitly admits that the
gospel of the Seventh Adventist Church
is a different gospel it isn't what
Jesus revealed to the apostles which was
handed down by them through the
centuries to the present day instead
it's the novel pillar doctrines of the
Adventist Church nestled Under The
Borrowed label of the Everlasting gospel
and if one takes umbrage with this it
will be seen as you not wanting to obey
Jesus and live a transformed life how
convenient right
thank you
what's up YouTube as always welcome to
the channel So today we're kicking off a
series of videos around the Cardinal
doctrines of the Christian faith and
examining seven-day adventism in light
of those this first series is focused on
the gospel in Romans 1 16-17 Paul writes
this
for I am not ashamed of the gospel for
it is the power of God for salvation to
everyone who believes to the Jew first
and also to the Greek for in it the
righteousness of God is revealed from
Faith to Faith as it is written but the
righteous will live by faith
so at a granular level much information
is packed into these two verses much of
which he expounds upon further in the
following chapters he tells us that it's
the gospel that is the power of God for
salvation to everyone that believes it
to both Jews and Gentiles alike it has a
Transcendent quality to it it isn't tied
to one people group or another nor is it
tied to only a specific generation of
people it doesn't more for change based
on what time period you live in further
evidence of this is found in Paul's
epistle to the Galatians where in the
first chapter he writes
I Marvel that you were so quickly
deserting him who called you by the
grace of Christ for a different gospel
which is really not another only there
are some who are disturbing you and want
to distort the gospel of Christ but if
we or an angel from heaven should
Proclaim to you a gospel contrary to the
gospel we have proclaimed to you let him
be accursed as we have said before so I
say again now if any man is proclaiming
to you a gospel contrary to what you
received let him be accursed
so it needs to be stated boldly and
plainly there is only one gospel that
saves this gospel that is the power of
God unto salvation cannot be altered
nothing can be added to it or taken away
or it is no longer Christ's gospel but a
different one which also means it cannot
save because only Christ gospel is the
power of God unto salvation he then
places a double curse on those who
proselytize a false cursed gospel by
saying let them be anathema which means
damned he goes on in Galatians 1 to
explain that he didn't receive this
gospel from man but from Jesus Christ
himself the apostles had the true gospel
revealed to them by Christ and they then
passed this gospel down through the
centuries to the present day it has not
changed it has not taken a new form or
shape to fit in our current day and age
it did not disappear and need to be
restored so in this series we're going
to examine a number of aspects of The
Seventh-Day Adventist gospel in light of
Jesus Christ once for All gospel so to
start in First Corinthians 15 1-8 Paul
gives us an excellent overview of
Christ's gospel he writes now I make
known to you Brothers The Gospel which I
proclaimed as good news to you which
also you received in which also you
stand by which also you are saved if you
hold fast the word which I Proclaim to
you as good news unless you believed for
nothing for I delivered to you as of
first importance what I also received
that Christ died for our sins according
to the scriptures and that he was buried
and that he was raised on the third day
according to the scriptures and that he
appeared to cephas then to the twelve
after that he appeared to more than 500
Brothers at one time most of whom remain
until now but some have fallen asleep
after that he appeared to James then to
all the apostles and last of all as to
one untimely born he also appeared to me
so the core of the Gospel is that Jesus
Christ died for our sins according to
the scriptures that he was buried and
that he was resurrected on the third day
according to the scriptures he was seen
by many eyewitnesses including all of
the 12 disciples and Paul the Apostle to
get even more specific and precise the
gospel is this man has broken God's law
and our sin has separated us from our
maker in his grace God entered into his
own Creation in the person of Jesus
Christ born of a virgin and lived a
perfect and sinless life fulfilling all
of the Law's demands on a mission by God
the Father to save sinners from
condemnation he paid the penalty for sin
which is death and bore the sins of his
people in his body on a cross making
propitiation by his blood he died was
buried and resurrected in the same body
he died in on the third day for our
justification by a living faith in the
person and work of Jesus God graciously
declares a person righteous they are
reconciled to their creator sealed with
the Holy Spirit and have peace with God
they are born again of the spirit
adopted into his family and are granted
Eternal Resurrection Life in Jesus
Christ set free to do good works that
please him Jesus will physically return
one day to judge the living and the dead
but his people will be spared from the
Wrath to come to dwell in Union with God
forever that is the gospel revealed by
Jesus Christ to the apostles that they
then penned down in the scriptures and
has been handed down to us today so now
let's look at how The Seventh-Day
Adventist faith and message lines up
with this the mission statement on their
website reads as follows
Make Disciples of Jesus Christ who live
as his loving Witnesses and Proclaim to
all people the Everlasting Gospel of the
Three Angels messages in preparation for
his soon return
so the gospel of adventism has been
branded with the term The Three Angels
messages the more common phrase you'll
hear them use for this is the
Everlasting gospel a phrase that is
found in Revelation 14 6. they also
State this in their official exposition
of their own beliefs it says
Prophecies of the Book of Revelation
clearly lay out the mission of the
remnant The Three Angels messages of
Revelation 14 6-12 reveal the
proclamation of the remnant that will
bring a full and final restoration of
the Gospel truth
so using a historicist approach to the
Book of Revelation they think that the
14th chapter is saying the fullness of
the Gospel fell away and that in the end
times God would raise up a remnant of
people who would restore it obviously
referring to themselves as the remnant
they also claim as Ellen White did that
the angels are representative of
themselves they're supposedly the ones
heralding these messages to the world we
know beyond a shadow of a doubt the
Everlasting Gospel of Revelation 14 is
not different than the gospel revealed
to the apostles as we've already seen
that there is only one Gospel of Jesus
Christ and all others are cursed the
Everlasting gospel is not different than
what Jesus had already revealed to the
Apostles of which John was one of so how
is the Adventist Church defining this
Everlasting gospel in a 2001 paper
titled what is the Everlasting gospel
Adventist Theologian Herbert Douglas
said this
this Everlasting gospel focuses on one
God to whom worship and obedience are
due and on two a people who give glory
to him during the time of his judgment
why is this emphasis on the Everlasting
gospel so timely so important so
necessary apparently there was something
about the gospel that had been muted or
muddled for some time before the events
seen in Revelation 14 requiring this
special Heavenly intervention to set
matters right especially at this
foretold time of his judgment so quickly
in passing I want to note something in
the next paragraph he says quote a brief
overview of church history for the past
200 years highlights a remarkable
confusion regarding the gospel that has
existed since Apostolic days he
continues in the same paragraph by
asking the question of where one would
find the gospel during the Reformation
era showcasing the Adventist Church's
lack of understanding around actual
church history the reformers did not
claim that the gospel was lost and
needed to be restored it's always been
here Christ's gospel will never be
extinguished remember it's the power of
God unto salvation for all that believe
it if it became truncated that means it
disappeared and the power of God into
salvation was lost for a Time keep this
in mind as this is an important Concept
in the Adventist understanding of the
Gospel he continues by saying if the
gospel includes more than telling the
story of Christ's death what is that
something more and why was an end time
correction needed in order for God to
get his final message across to Seekers
of Truth before Jesus returns so notice
in the Adventist worldview the gospel
disappeared became distorted for a long
period of time and is supposedly being
restored to its fullness by the
Adventist Church and the unique end
times message that they are heralding
throughout this paper which I'll link to
in the description box he misrepresents
historic Christianity with the common
SDA claims like no one else teaches
obedience to God or that one experiences
a transformed life when they come to
Christ which is so unbelievably false I
don't even know where to start but in
the final paragraph of the paper we read
this
the purpose of the Gospel is to make
plain why Jesus came and why he died the
Everlasting gospel in the end times
restores the New Testament gospel in its
wholeness in its Integrity it explains
God's plan to save men and women in such
a way that their presence in the new
Earth would not jeopardize again the
well-being and security of the universe
so if you read this paper you're going
to see that he makes a differentiation
between what he calls limited gospels
and the Everlasting Gospel of the end
times that the Adventist Church is
supposedly restoring and heralding to
the world he says that these limited
gospels only focus on the death burial
and resurrection of Jesus omitting the
aspect of a transformed life in
obedience to Christ to which I say again
what utter nonsense and secondly in the
words of Paul the Apostle I'm determined
to know nothing among you except Christ
and him crucified so is that it a
transformed life and obedience that's
all that the SDA church is restoring
that's what supposedly fell away and
needed restored in the end times what do
they mean by this he doesn't get into
the finer details so we have to go to an
another source for that in the November
29 1934 issue overview in Herald we find
the specifics where it says
this movement with which we are
connected stands for certain great
fundamental truths the existence of God
the inspiration of the Holy scriptures
salvation alone through the vicarious
sacrifice of the Lord Jesus repentance
regeneration and the gift of
righteousness by faith the work of the
Holy Spirit the immutability of God's
law The Binding claims of the Bible
Sabbath the Priestly Ministry of Christ
in the Heavenly Sanctuary the
investigative judgment now going on the
soon coming of Christ to take his
children home the doctrine of spiritual
gifts the manifestation of the gift of
Prophecy in the remnant Church Life only
in Christ Christian Temperance and other
leading important Bible doctrines these
great truths constitute the Everlasting
gospel message for this time they
continue in the next column by saying to
the Seventh Adventist Church has been
committed this message the Everlasting
gospel was preached by Noah by Abraham
by Paul and Peter and by all the
prophets and apostles of past ages it
was preached in the setting appropriate
to their day we cannot preach this
gospel message as Noah preached it or as
Paul or Luther gave it it is for us to
preach it in the setting of God's Great
3 4 bold message of Revelation 14.
Luther preached righteousness by faith
in the setting of The Gospel message for
the 16th century we must preach
righteousness by faith in the setting of
God's message for this time we are told
by the messenger of the Lord quoting
Ellen White here several have written to
me inquiring if the message of
justification by faith is the third
Angel's message and I have answered it
is the third Angel's message in Verity
the Apostle Paul preached of
righteousness and Temperance and of a
judgment to come we cannot preach the
Judgment of God as did the Apostle we
must preach the hour of his judgment is
come that judgment is now going forward
the great underlying principles of these
truths are the same but in our preaching
their application must be made to
present day conditions and then down on
the next page is a quote from
testimonies for the church volume 6 by
Ellen White which says no line of truth
that has made the Seventh-day Adventist
people what they are is to be weakened
we have the old landmarks of Truth
experience and Duty and we are to stand
firmly in defense of our principles in
full view of the world so here we're
given a clear outline of what all this
Everlast lasting gospel supposedly
entails among a host of beliefs that
they have borrowed and redefined such as
righteousness by faith a topic for
another video we also find Adventist
pillar doctrines such as The Seventh-Day
Sabbath which they call the Bible
Sabbath the investigative judgment the
work of Christ in the Heavenly Sanctuary
which is a part of their atonement model
and the gift of prophecy manifested
through Ellen G white who we saw a quote
from regarding these pillars where she
said Adventists have the old landmarks
of Truth and they are never to be
weakened which is rather odd considering
that these are doctrines that are for
this time to be preached in this setting
but at the same time they are supposedly
restoring Apostolic Christianity right
this was followed up by them saying that
this message cannot be preached the same
way that others have through the
centuries because those people didn't
live in our setting you're also seeing
the Adventist doctrine of present truth
on display here which is really just
relative truth so this article tacitly
admits that the gospel of the Seventh
Adventist Church is a different gospel
it isn't what Jesus revealed to the
apostles which was handed down by them
through the centuries present day
instead it's the novel pillar doctrines
of the Adventist Church nestled Under
The Borrowed label of the Everlasting
gospel and if one takes umbrage with
this it will be seen as you not wanting
to obey Jesus and live a transformed
life how convenient right and this gets
us back to what I was saying earlier
about the assumptions that the Adventist
Church brings to the table it's
important to understand these the
assumption that the gospel fell away for
a period of time and needed restored a
claim that all the restorationist groups
make the assumption that the gospel
Proclamation looks different at
different periods of time and isn't a
unified Transcendent definite message
the assumption that church history spans
no more than a mere 200 years into the
past and the lack of understanding
around the reformation and what the real
issues were the assumption that
different denominations all claim to
have different gospels and you have to
find the right one like a needle in a
haystack
no pun intended and a plethora of others
that we will explore along our journey
down this Rabbit Hole the Gospel of
Jesus Christ never disappeared it never
got lost or needed restored Jesus Christ
possesses all authority in heaven and on
Earth this is the authority that the
disciples were sent out with in Matthew
28 to take the gospel to the nations in
the next part of the series we will
begin dissecting this false gospel Angel
by Angel starting with the first Angels
message if you found today's video
helpful would you please be so kind to
smash that like button subscribe and
ring the notification Bell so you can be
notified when the next part is uploaded
as always until next time God bless
[Music]